Accomodati Maria Adelaide finalmente ci
vediamo tua madre è molto preoccupata lo
sai vero Ma parliamo di te Raccontami un
po' chi sei Quali sono i tuoi hobby sei
Maria dell'aid e ti piacciono i casi
umani tu non lotta di classe tu in
questo modo questo la tirare
l'attenzione ma tagliamo la testa alla
Pecora parlami un po' di questo ragazzo
che cosa ti ha trasmesso in questi mesi
la clami la clamidia Maria dell'adelaide
lasciamo per un attimo da parte le
malattie Venere che Adelaide Però pure
tu ma che Futura ti può dare Marco lo
spacciatore Ma allora se i suoi in un
caseificio Convincilo a lavorare
nell'azienda di famiglia Ma dove a papà
chiedo provincia di Sassari ma non sarà
mica il figlio di Antonio selus ma il
fratello da cugino di secondo grado del
marito di mia zia Pina ma pensa a te ma
Salutamelo tanto ma digli di mandarmi un
po' di pecorino E comunque ricordati che
l'amore è maturo dice ti amo perché ho
bisogno di te l'amore è maturo invece
dice
Daniela non so cosa succede ma è andato
in Grecia aforismi.it e chiama il
tecnico perché ci fa essere un problema
con la rete e dice che te lo dico la
prossima volta